Johnson & Johnson vows to appeal a
record 4.7 billion dollar jury award to
22 women and their families
the plaintiffs argued that Johnson and
Johnson's talcum powder products like
baby powder caused them to develop
ovarian cancer this was the first trial
to argue that talc and baby powder
contains cancer-causing asbestos one of
the plaintiffs told CBS News the verdict
means quote no little girls will have to
go through what I went through Johnson &
Johnson said in a statement it is deeply
disappointed and remains confident that
its products do not contain asbestos and
do not cause ovarian cancer CBS News
legal analyst Ricky Kleeman is with us
this morning
Ricky welcome the deliberations lasted
less than an hour what does that seem
awfully short well we have to divide it
up into the two halves of this trial
deliberations were eight hours for the
compensatory damages that's still by the
way really short reminder compensatory
wills for six weeks of testimony
including a myriad of experts
compensation is compensatory what did
you suffer did you lose your life did
you have injuries did you have treatment
conscious pain and suffering things that
we can actually calculate then each side
after that verdict which was 550 million
dollars divided by 22 plaintiffs or
approximately 25 million apiece which by
the way is a little strange that every
plaintiff gets basically the same then
10 minutes argument each side for
punitive zhh what are punitive 'he's
just like it sounds
punishment so how are we going to punish
johnson and johnson in order to give a
message to the world which is what it
was argued to do any time what was the
message though I mean they they're
punishing johnson johnson that's a lot
of punishment it's actually one of the
most extraordinary amounts of money and
punitive damages what you have is four
point one four billion with a b dollars
in punitive down
as a punishment but they calculated that
I'm not so sure they calculated the
compensatory z' they calculated by
looking at it this way seventy million
dollars was what Johnson and Johnson
earned on the talc products by the way
it's not only baby powder it's also
shower to shower let's not forget so
what they did was they looked at that
times forty-three years and they looked
at their net worth and the net worth
here 63 billion dollars in two thousand
eighteen thirteen billion dollars for
Johnson Johnson consumer was very well
calculated to come up with the billions
but we have to look at the appeal the
appeal is critical Johnson & Johnson is
very confident this will get reduced by
the judge or reversed on appeal they've
been very successful in their post trial
practice big big big trial to watch
unworthy number of cases here thousand
nine thousand in the wind Ricky thanks
as always